[Musique]
ce sont les petites pièces en plastique
les plus célèbres au monde ici 1500
pièces de Lego sont exposé pour faire
rêver les enfants et pas
seulement j'en ai eu petit ça se
transmet de génération en génération et
puis c'est toujours intéressant à à voir
quoi il y a de belles choses il y a
beaucoup de legos que j'adore qui soit
vieux ou pas je les aime puis j'aimerais
les avoir dans ma chambre derrière cette
collection se cache un passionné de Lego
depuis 60 ans armé de patience et de
minutie il a construit chaque pièce de
l'exposition en 3 mois je me suis
surpris moi-même quand j'ai vu la
quantité que que j'avais je vois que les
gens sont aussi aussi impressionnés que
que je l'étais à la première vue quoi il
me remercie de leur de leur montrer leur
jouer leur enfance parce que vous avez
tous les âges vous avez toutes les
époques toujours à laaffu des
videsgreniers ou des ventes Maus il
détient des pied pièces très anciennes
ça ce sont des boîtes de
1958 donc avec des pièces
neuves pour la médiathèque le succès est
garanti l'exposition a été visitée par
plus de 6000 visiteurs et permet de
toucher un nouveau public on a également
plein de touristes qui profitent du
marché Noël et qui viennent à la
médiathèque visiter l'exposition c'est
vrai que c'est intergénérationnel on a
les enfants les parents les
grands-parents et vraiment tous les âges
et toutes les nationalités on pense
atteindre les 10000 visiteurs ce qui est
exceptionnel on on a vraiment jamais eu
cette fréquentation sur une autre
exposition à la médiathèque cette
exposition a de quoi donner des idées au
Père Noël et restera visible jusqu'au 6
janvier à la
médiathèque